[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute das schoko
brötchen
wie passt es zum schulstart weil
schokopudding hätte ich immer in der
schule mit und erzähle euch noch etwas
witziger ist meine freundin und ich
übrigens heute noch meine beste freundin
haben uns in der grundschule immer
unsere pausenbrote getauscht weil die
hatte immer das hat er sich immer woher
genau so ne truthahn wurst und ich hatte
halt immer in der schoko brötchen oder
was hätte ich für elf jahre übertroffen
werden
ja ja klar warum hat ich brauche selber
gemacht nee also und harte schnitte
nicht selbst macht einfach viel viel
besser und herren ich drück gemacht auf
instagram weil ich die gemacht habe und
diesen so fähig kennt ihr diese gebäcke
die ihr zusammenpressen einfach wieder
aufgehen so sind wie und jetzt werde ich
auch gar nicht lange drumherum schneider
und ich hab mir mal in der hand schon im
teig also e mail und ich gebe da direkt
die prise salz dazu und es trocken
die trockenhefe ihr könnt auch
verschiedene von dem man nimmt einfach
ein heim würfel dann gebe ich schon mal
zucker mit dazu
also zu seinem flügel steht sonst mit
der definitiven infobox
ja so lust drauf und jetzt bin ich ein
modell gebe da einmal die lauwarme milch
und die geschmolzene butter habe ich in
der mikrowelle geschmolzen und etwas
abkühlen lassen und erst mit den
sauberen patsche hinten rein und einfach
zu einem teig verkneten
[Musik]
meine lieben ich habe dem teig jetzt
hier auf der arbeitsfläche geknetet ich
brauche dafür überhaupt keine
küchenmaschine weil das geht so schnell
in zwei minuten oder drei habt ihr schon
so ein schöner tag schaut mal wie schon
gesagt die oberfläche ist und jetzt
müssen wir das ganze gehen lassen für 45
minuten zugedeckt ich mache das so es
gibt bestimmte hefeteig da mache ich
einfach die schüssel voll mit ein
bisschen nie oben drüber ein bisschen
mehl der getrocknet aber aus wenn wir
den nicht mit öl oder mit fett benetzen
da nämlich backt raumspray wir können
natürlich auch ganz normales öl aus der
flasche nehmen aber es kann man halt
besser dosieren
einfach rein lägen auf jeden fall auf
die oberfläche nochmal backt rems bringt
und jetzt wie gesagt zugedeckt an einem
warmen ort gehen lassen und 45 minuten
sehen wir uns wieder für den teich ist
schon aufgegangen mindestens doppelt so
dick ist ja jetzt dann ist nämlich raus
aus der schüssel und das geht auch super
einfach
und jetzt kommt der meiner meinung nach
beste teil jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere
schoko treppchen die sind backfisch und
die gibt es hier einfach über den teig
und dann zügig ein kneten weil wir haben
gehandelt wärme also ich übertreibe
immer gern ein bisschen schon
zügig jetzt ein arbeiten weil er mehr
hand wärme und sonne schokolade schmilzt
[Musik]
nachdem ich es einige sekunden ganz kurz
an gearbeitet habe nämlich in meinen
teil karte und steht mir hier aus dem
großen teigklumpen zehn kleinere teil
kolinger aus und diese dann ganz einfach
zu kugeln formen
[Musik]
und jetzt das die bombe und total
hochqualitatives schwimmbad das sein
dass wir das auch schon gerne benutzen
ok die rede ist von meinem backblech
aber in diesem video will ich euch
darüber nicht so viel erzählen da kommt
ein extra video auf jeden fall ein
produkt auf das ich mega mega stolz bin
das belege ich jetzt mit backpapier dann
sieht man ein wunderschönes logo leider
nicht mehr
aber es ist schon zweimal mit backpapier
belegen und dann und dann einfach die
teiglinge drauflegen mit etwas abstand
und dann decken
und weil sie noch etwas aufgehen werden
genau die werden größer und dann denke
ich sie ab und lasst sie noch mal 20
minuten gehen
ja das ist gut das ist gut weil komme
ich natürlich fragen wir uns nicht
beantwortet ja ich hole ich ach so ja
hier sind meint auch so und jetzt wie
gesagt mit einem tuch bedecken und in 20
minuten sehen wir uns wieder wenn ihr 30
minuten zeit habt dann macht es auch
gerne 30 minuten aufnehmen aber
mindestens 20 und solltet ihr schon
einheiten
bis gleich das ergebnis nach der zweiten
rot zeit also sind noch einmal deutlich
aufgegangen und milchbrötchen wenn keine
milch ruhig hin wenn das hier ist jetzt
nicht noch mit milch bestreichen würden
also vor dem backen und dann übrigens
hier gar kein rezept das finde ich ganz
cool so eifrige rezepte gehen ja immer
man hat er nicht immer da und ich
bestreite dass jetzt in dambach ist
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt noch ein bisschen milch
übrig das benutzen wir gleich denn jetzt
kommt erstmal in den backofen bei 190
grad ober und unterhitze für ca 25
minuten und nach dem backen ganz ganz
wichtig das sage ich jetzt schon mal
nehmen wir die milch und bestreichen die
milchbrötchen heißt noch mal mit milch
und dann können wir sie aus können dass
beziehungsweise lauwarm essen also bis
nachher meinem spricht nicht gerade ganz
frisch aus dem ofen tut mir eingefallen
und schaut schon bei 20 minuten nach bei
mir haben sie heute 23 minuten gebraucht
und jetzt viel gesagt noch ganz heiß mit
dem milch bestreichen die milch ist ganz
einfach nur lauwarm bis kalt also da
müsste jetzt nicht besonders viel
beachten und danach könnte so leicht
abkühlen lassen ich mag die gern lauwarm
oder auch kalt und die bleiben wirklich
zwei bis drei tage lang richtig schön
frisch und fluffig wichtig ist hat man
dass ihr das ganze luftdicht verpackt
entweder in der brotdose oder ihr macht
es einfach macht sich die ganze zeit
über ein tuch ich weiß dass es vier oder
fünf auf einmal gegessen
an vieles aber auch schon es ist
vollkommen okay
[Musik]
sie sind noch 190 grad heiß aber ich
zeige euch trotzdem schon mal wie vor
wichtig sind
guckt mal genau das meine ich davon habe
ich gesprochen
er drückt ihr drückt und mache ich das
mal ich muss einmal aufmachen
hartmann hat verbringt gerade mein gott
das ist wie meine schwester ich sagen
würde dass im jugendalter flüssigkeit
des todes auf jeden fall sehen dass die
flowfact milchbrötchen mit dem verso
schoko brüchen die ich je gegessen habe
und ich weiß bäckereien sind auch toll
aber keine bäckerei happ zu sehen
bekommen ganz ehrlich ich hab noch nie
so lag oder oder ich sagen würde das ist
okay das ist okay auf jeden fall so dass
wirklich die flow fixen wirklich er war
einfach und ihr habt doch gesehen
zutaten hat man immer da also alles habe
ich immer da auch die schoko drops und
ich habt ihr bestimmt auch macht das war
macht es nachlegen wollte ich ja nicht
böse ist macht es auf jeden fall nach
kostet ist mit dem hashtag kiki sketchen
auf instagram gerne auch auf facebook
und dann freue ich mich natürlich wenn
ihr diesem video einen daumen nach oben
gibt wenn euch das rezept gefallen hat
und hinterlasst doch gerne meinen
kommentar weshalb er seine jugend oder
in der kindheit auf dem pausenhof gerne
gegessen schreibt gerne mal rein das
wirklich auch immer sehr interessiert
ja klar
mit alufolie hat das gefühl hier früher
war man sich gar nicht so dessen bewusst
jetzt hat man natürlich der
frischhaltedosen der umwelt zuliebe
bestimmt ich weiß auf jeden fall mal
rein soll das war cool zur pausenhof
stories so viel feierei und schottin die
infobox dasteht alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben drin und ansonsten
natürlich moment ich bin gleich wieder
da und das aber nicht vergessen es ist
komplett kostenlos und die glocke
aktivieren und dann verpasst ja auch
kein video mehr von uns einen schrieb
gestern auf instagram bei wir hatten uns
auf instagram gezeigt schreibt so das
hat sich an die abo nicht vergessen
naja egal ich wünsche euch jetzt noch
wunderschönen tag und wir sehen uns im
nächsten rezept videos möglichkeit des
turbo calls
[Musik]